[Music]
[Applause]
nick wright first things first co-host
on fox sports one uh joining us on the
program good to see you nick how are you
you played augusta dan yes i did
so why don't you just
is it faster to just figure out the
courses you haven't played um there's a
lot of courses i haven't played i've
been for andrews yeah played that
okay um pebble beach yes
okay yeah so maybe it is faster to go
with the ones you haven't played maybe
some in dubai or something uh cyprus
cyprus is a really difficult golf course
to get on
did you play it the one in detroit that
just burnt down no pokemon i think it is
uh oakmont is in pennsylvania i think
okay well then there's a famous one in
detroit oh kills burn burn down i think
oh kills i think that's it oh okay do
you play
you know i
no i i want to and i said that this
summer i was going to dedicate like that
was going to be my leisure thing is to
be able to be i just want to break 90 so
i can when people such as yourself
invite me out not that you ever would i
can say yes right now i can't say yes
because i'm not good enough but
i just found out last week that i'm
basically a professional fisherman deep
sea variety so i think that's what i'm
going to do this summer instead deep sea
fishing
i would like to uh invite you to play
golf with me see
you you did that because you knew i just
said i'm not good enough all right once
i get good enough i'm playing okay you
break
you break 90
how's that
deal it's a goal
thank you dan how about we do surf and
turf golf and fishing
oh
oh deal i'll teach you how to fish
because you don't look like a fisherman
um well your hands are too soft i'm a
too much life of luxury i'm an angler
and i am actually a fly fisherman
that doesn't seem fun that just seems
like an excuse to drink no
no no no if you go deep sea fishing
that's when you drink when you go fly
fishing
you have to work every single cast you
got to work you got to work no it's
competition
but how big are the fish they go it's
like this big mm-hmm for radio listeners
i'm making
you can catch some pretty good fish
and on a fly rod it feels bigger
oh it does it yes it does oh okay just
just just letting you know here uh
first reaction to the calvin ridley
story was
well listen obviously he has to be in
trouble and
a wide number of reactions as a gambler
i'd like to see the venn diagram of
people that have uttered these words i
don't have a gambling problem and people
that actually have a gambling problem
because that that did concern me but
when i saw what the bets were
a 3 5 and 18 parlay i'm like okay so
this guy's not like a gambler he's just
nick can you hold on for a sec
yeah i got breaking news
[Music]
we have the results of the aaron rodgers
story
oh okay
so paulie knows
we don't know
now
does he stay in green bay or does he go
and if he goes where does he go
he's staying okay if i'm wrong and he's
going
it's pittsburgh okay
i've said all along if he left it was
going to be denver and i thought the
longer this went on he was going to
leave paulie give us the information
here aaron rodgers is according to ian
rappaport of nfl network
the packers and mvp aaron rodgers have
agreed in terms on a four-year 200
million deal that makes him the highest
paid player in nfl history sources say
wow he gets a whopping 153 million
guaranteed and his cap number actually
goes down four years 200 million
wow
such a joke
the whole thing
why is that i mean
because it was it really was always the
whole thing was about money
this whole dance and i'm gonna go host
jeopardy and i'm gonna and i'm gonna i'm
on a self-actualization
and the pen and they they got rid of
kumaru and they don't respect me that
and i you know and i miss alan lazard
over the middle so i lose to jimmy
garoppolo at home scoring seven points
the whole thing was so he can be he make
50 million
that's the whole thing we've gone
through all this nonsense oh i want to
live in denver i want to go to the
titans it's so all so we can make 50
million
give me a break like that
and by the way though this is what i
don't understand and i'm and i'm all for
athletes making a ton of money i don't
think athletes are overpaid but i do
think in a hard capped sport that this
is you have to do this math i would have
thought that if a genie went to aaron
rodgers 18 months ago and said
will you will you take 10 million
out of your bank account
and i will change the result of that
seattle nfc championship game where you
guys botch the onside kick you go to
that super bowl you beat tom brady you
have two rings 10 million for that i
think he would have said yes he's now
telling me no in fact i will make it
harder to win the next one because the
team's gonna be worse and then when
they're not as good and he's not as good
in the playoffs as he is in the regular
season again what we're going to hear is
i don't have enough talent around me i
need more help
but
50 million
50 million okay
what else do you have paulie a little
more from ian rappaport according to uh
his sources rogers was down to
retirement the packers or the broncos
before the decision was made
okay no offense broncos
i feel bad for the broncos because they
geared up for this
and uh
well he'll have some things to say i'm
sure on pat mcafee's show
later today but i know when von miller
left they wanted to make sure they got a
second round pick they were going to
load up those picks to go to green bay
yes
he does
sorry to interrupt but according to pat
mcafee news of the four year according
to pat mcafee's sources who knows what
they could be
news of a four-year 200 million dollar
deal is not accurate oh okay so i guess
this story's not over uh is he staying
is that accurate that's all i care about
yes he is staying with the package i
don't care about the money cap friendly
deal yeah and i'm going to guess his
source is rogers so
first of all how does mac listen
macbeth's done a great job there's no
shade but how does mcphee not break this
i thought he was going to we're signing
a new deal
and paulie doesn't break it bad job
paulie yeah like that is like what in
the world or okay
this is
it's just so maddening the whole thing
and listen
you and i are both in the money and
attention business i get it i like
attention i like money
i'm not i so i feel like it's a little
glass houses thing i'm doing here
but
the the whole thing feels fraudulent the
whole thing feels like he was squeezing
them for dollars
that he wasn't going to denver he
doesn't want to face mahomes twice a
year
the guy
best i can tell he he skipped this last
chief's game and get out of fear him a
home people said hey
kobet reasons i think he didn't want
mullins to crush it
uh you know what we're in the rooting
business we root for change we root for
stories that we can talk about
and i think the media rooted for stories
they rooted for tennessee oh my god
pittsburgh did you hear mike tomlin what
he said about roger denver
it felt like that whereas staying in
green bay
that doesn't you know that doesn't
change much it's like okay aaron rodgers
stays there
yes
correct and i think the tomlin thing
would have been super interesting and i
think seeing him in the same division as
mahomes and herbert would have been
super interesting i agree with that we
root for interesting and to be right
like that's what we root for yeah um
but
the other the other part of it is we
this wasn't out of whole cloth
he started this whole thing on draft day
last year
well that was schefter shafter started
this on draft day because that wasn't a
story on draft day because it felt like
that was imminent that he was going to
be traded and then asking schefter about
that on my show i said that you didn't
have any breaking news that day and he
said it was just a compilation of things
but it wasn't my point is this wasn't a
media creation the frustration was real
the flirting with retirement the the
thinking go host jeopardy yeah all that
was real and then all of i'm the most
interesting man in the world because i
read one and ran book all that happened
and then and then the the bizarre
instagram post that's because he was on
a a a a b pollen cleanse that happened
all of it happened
and and the end result is oh i was never
leaving but i got the most money any
players ever gotten good for you
he's nick right first things first
co-host on fox sports one the reason why
i was going to have you on the main
reason was
lebron on the shop coming out saying hey
i get pissed off nobody ever talks about
me as being a great scorer one of the
great scorers of all time
i view that as a compliment because
you know alex english and adrian dently
and carmelo anthony those are great
scores
lebron could be the greatest player of
all time
so i didn't know if he was manufacturing
something to say well let me ask you
this do who do you think is better
considered a better scorer lebron or
durant
durant
but they average to the tenth of a point
the exact same amount of points per game
for their career and lebron does it on a
higher efficiency
who do you think's a better score lebron
or kobe
kobe is viewed as a better score
but lebron averages more points on a
better percentage and a better
three-point percentage so i think that's
the frustration yeah but
his game is so much more balanced than
durance or kobe's that it that
i i don't look at lebron and say he's a
scorer i mean he is a scorer he's not a
shooter he's a scorer but he's he's the
best all-around player who's ever played
the game
that's the better compliment to call you
a scorer
well yes and kobe was a pure shooter
durant's a far pure shooter
lebron knows how to score
it's not always pretty but he kobe and
durant got style points it's the pretty
and it's the style it's that because
so much of nba
analysis is not who's the most effective
it's who reminds me the most of michael
jordan and jordan while early in his
career was a high flyer he with the when
he was winning championships it was
mid-range it was jump shots it was that
kind of balletic scoring and lebron
it's one of the reasons why people
almost like have discounted some of his
buzzer beaters because they came
remember the one in the playoffs against
the pacers came on a layup he had a
buzzer beating layup and so like like
well that doesn't really count well it
does it literally counts and it's the
because it is not scoring the way
people are used to seeing people score
but i think you could argue like this
it's what's interesting when we talk
about the greatest scores in nba history
people aren't
they'll list five names before
mentioning
one two and three in all-time scoring
malone and lebron and so like now i
think you can argue obviously jordan was
the best scorer ever because he just
didn't play long enough but he was 33 a
game in the playoffs 30 game for his
career but other than jordan i think
lebron's got his case for anyone but
lebron's got to create these little
you know yes
well it goes to punch at yeah that's
what i thought he was doing that okay
this season is lost
now i'm gonna focus on passing karl
malone maybe i can be uh you know
herculean and i can uh we we can do
surprise somebody in the playoffs maybe
but uh this just felt like it was
another motivational tool
that's fair can i do i know i'm only on
with you like once a month but can i can
i start every time i'm on with you can
we do one thing at the end i don't know
if we're near the end but i would like
do it okay where i predict a future take
that's coming that's getting ready it's
in the hopper not for me
not from you in this show but a take
that is going to be in the sports media
you know ether okay
lebron james
is selfish for winning the scoring title
lebron james winning the scoring title
is actually not good lebron j if lebron
james was not as focused on winning the
scoring title
maybe
he would you know shut it down for the
year maybe the lakers would be better
off it is going to be a cuddle used
against him
mark my words yeah i could see it
look but you work on a network where you
have somebody who looks at what is the
negative lebron james story and if there
isn't one skip bayless creates it so oh
i thought you're talking about kevin
wilds it works on my show wow that's the
song
yeah listen there
there needs to be balance in the
universe dan
and so there's me
have you ever called out skip bayless
for one of his takes i was on i i was
sitting across table from him uh right
before
my our show launched uh the day
game three of the finals in cleveland
the first year the warriors had durant
when durant hit the shot
on lebron to go up 3-0 yeah we had a
nice
15 minutes back and forth okay i i
landed a nice i i will say i was proud i
needed landed a pretty nice nice one
because we that that then turned into a
discussion about the championship with
cleveland the year before and i was told
uh kyrie irving hit the game-winning
shot and i said
no no kyrie irving didn't win the game
going up by three
in the finals doesn't win you the game
you know i would have thought ray allen
taught everybody that going up by three
because this is what people forget game
seven against the warriors the clinching
points were made by one lebron raymond
james right after draymond green
brutalized him i thought he broke his
wrist he wolverined it back and he
heroically made a free throw that's what
won the game going up four wins of the
game going up three is nice four wins
you the game history will run all right
so we're predicting hot ticks i like it
no i didn't say hot takes it's just
going to be in the ether it's going to
be out there who said it's a hot take
but you know what i think just like
russell westbrook thinks west brick has
turned into not a slur but something
very pejorative i think hot take is
pejorative people are like oh i always
have these writers they they send these
little tweets they're like oh these hot
take artists on television like first of
all artist correct second of all take it
correct third of all what do you
has anyone ever been like hey give me
some lukewarm soup no you want some hot
soup things that are hot are supposed to
be good they're more delicious
they're more attractive yeah so i i you
know what that's what i'm doing i'm
reclaiming the word hot take is a
positive thank you nick
no problem i'll talk to you later okay
that's uh nick wright first things first
co-host fox sports one fretzi book nick
in a month from now i got it okay